oh my gosh okay look here they are the
new air pods pro 2.
[Music]
these are so awesome and i love the fact
that they have a built-in lanyard i feel
like that's something that was missing
on basically all of the airpods but now
it's here and they also have a speaker
which if you have airpods leave me a
comment below how many times have you
lost your airpods and then found them
this will actually help you find them
easier because you'll be able to
actually hear the sound much louder so
i'm very very excited about that this
has a pretty similar design to the
previous version but it has the brand
new h2 chip it has high band
connectivity new low distortion driver
with custom amplifier it also has
personalized spatial audio so you'll be
able to use ios 16 to scan your ear you
may have seen me talk before about
sony's headphones because they have a
similar thing where you can actually
scan your ear to get customized audio
well now the airpods actually have that
too so you're going to be able to scan
your ear and be able to get customized
spatial audio depending upon the shape
of your ear which is pretty awesome
because as we know we all have different
shaped ears and sometimes a lot of air
pods don't work for my ears so i'm very
excited to try this out to get
customized audio we also now have
smaller ear tips which is also very
exciting because i do have trouble
sometimes with these in my ears with the
case you'll be able to get about 30
hours of battery life and listening time
you'll get about six hours which is
increased from the previous version it
does have the adaptive transparency mode
i love using the airpods pro when i'm on
a flight or if i'm out and about and
these do have noise cancellation that
has been improved and it's supposed to
be two times stronger so that's going to
be really fun to kind of test that out
in comparison to the previous version
another thing i'm excited about is
you'll be able to now charge your
airpods case with the apple watch
charger and this is really exciting
because i always travel with the little
dual charger and sometimes i'm charging
my phone and i want to charge my air
pods at the same time but now i can
actually use the apple watch section of
that and charge my airpods got left oh
yeah active noise cancellation is on so
let's change it to transparency so we
can talk for one second
i hear everything a lot of times with
these headphones you hear kind of like
this tinny kind of sound
and it
kind of hurts your ears whereas these do
not do that it sounds very clean very
natural and actually
they fit as well
it sounds so good
[Music]
so i don't want to i feel like i'm
talking i don't know if i'm talking loud
because i can't hear myself but now with
the active noise cancellation on it told
me that my noise levels are okay because
i'm blocking out a lot of the sound this
is so great
i'm so glad i decided to do the demo one
more thing to try we have one more thing
touch controls and volume okay so the
touch controls are actually really
awesome so now i'm turning it up and
turning it down
music's going up
music's going down the only thing that
would make this better is if tim cook
and harry styles
walked out of the steve jobs theater
right now we can only help
we can oh my gosh awesome these were so
cool
wow
thank you so much so here they are the
new airpods pro 2 right here i'll see
you guys in my next video
you